i i have this like i don't know if this
is like tinfoil hat a part of me just
thinks is youtube just trying to shift
all the drama
onto like twitter like you can't you
could you like now right let's say
you know you can't you can't dislike
something publicly let's say the
comments are filtered
yeah i wonder is youtube just being like
go to twitter go and argue on twitter
don't [ __ ]
i didn't think about that but uh that's
uh
now it's you know with the dislikes gone
what is there to do other than comment
and you know a lot of the time with
these videos people are going to turn
off comments right yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
great just even more toxicity towards
twitter
i do i do wonder because you know if you
know even if the youtube creative all
the shit's going down on twitter
youtube can be like oh i mean i i i feel
like that's not going to happen because
there are such there's been such an
increase in like commentary and drama
channels now
that the conversation is still going to
stay on youtube
it's just a lot of people maybe can only
publicly comment on about it
also also if anything it does really
seem like
to on at first glance it does seem like
everyone who is following something on
youtube
also uses twitter but that is really not
the case like i
i very quickly found out that yes even
though i might have a massive following
on twitter
compared to like the people who use
youtube it's really not
a lot it's not even the majority of
people yeah like
i remember like there was one time where
like i posted something on my twitter
and then i talked about it on my youtube
and i got a lot of people being like
well i don't use twitter
yeah but in the back of my head i was
like oh yeah there are some people who
don't use twitter
i mean i think it's gotten to the point
now where i've kind of had this
realization where
every platform is kind of like in its
own it's most of the time it's in its
own bubble right right
you can be really really popular on one
platform and then open an account on
another platform and just have like like
zero followers i mean there's so many
like you know youtubers who have a
million plus subs on their
youtube but then when you go onto their
twitter they have you know less than
fifty thousand followers
like the content right that's like kind
of how it you know yeah
but like also like i can't imagine how
many [ __ ] tick tockers i just don't
know about just because i'm not on the
platform oh yeah yeah
and the thing is like they they can open
a twitter account because to me like
the the way i see twitter now is just
like [ __ ] influence of facebook
it literally is that's basically what
it's like for me now and
like sometimes i hear about a tick tock
who has like [ __ ] millions and
millions of followers on tick tock opens
her twitter and it's like
like you know less followers than us
even though they have like more
followers on their own platform
right in youtube terms if they had that
many subscribers
on like youtube then there would be
massive creators
not all followers subscribers are
created equal though right yeah yeah
that's true that's true
like it it also really depends on how
much you
focus and post on that platform yeah
that's true like and how much you're
known by your audience to use that
platform yeah yeah exactly
yeah man i i i wondered because i i'm
thinking like
you know as content creators you know
if you're somebody who say does not give
a [ __ ]
about anything and you're like i don't
care people say about me i feel like the
only
really tool that like an audience or a
platform has
to kind of um what's the word police
or give feedback is like public shaming
almost
i feel like getting rid of the dislike
is a part of like you know
taking away from that because i feel
like as content creations uh
content creation creators sorry my gosh
you know the only real tool
other than like youtube deleting your
channel is like you know
and it sounds bad because it sounds
really [ __ ] terrifying is it public
shaming but that's like the only real
tool that is there to like stop you from
doing shitty stuff yeah yeah most of the
time
for a lot of people yeah yeah who are
questionable because i don't think i
don't think
removing the dislike button is not going
to get rid of toxicity yeah you know
it's it's not it's like it's just going
to get people to figure out
other creative ways no it's reduce that
toxin exactly right
all that's going to happen is it's going
to shift into another form
and i feel like to me i removing the
dislike button is just
so weird to me because it's just
censorship i don't think it's that i
don't think it's censorship
i mean i feel it's like a form of it
right because again like
you know if there's again like a video
where it's an apology video or something
controversial
and you turn off the comments and the
dislikes aren't shown well then how else
are you supposed to
say anything about it i feel like the
term censorship gets thrown around a lot
nowadays
you know i feel like this is pushing the
definition of what censorship is but
what it is is
that it's removing a way for us to
express ourselves
and um i've i i wonder if it's a similar
case to
when um you know when the whole
kids v the kids on youtube thing where
they were like all doing like
gymnastics or something people
commenting gross things and then
youtube's trump's response was well
we'll just turn off all the comments for
kids videos
and then you're just like well there's
no more pedophiles on youtube now
they're all gone
if you can't see them they're not there
right where are they there's no
negativity on youtube there's no
dislikes what do you mean
you know this is it almost feels like
that youtube's like if you just remove
the option to show it publicly to anyone
it doesn't exist it's just the whole
like see no evil you know evil there's
[ __ ] tons of videos of kids doing
probably inappropriate things on youtube
still like that [ __ ] creeps are
probably still watching them right yeah
yeah but now it's harder to [ __ ] find
these videos and report them because
like you know how the [ __ ] are you
supposed to when you know there's not
like a bunch of creepy dudes in the
comments unless you like actively go out
and search for those videos but who the
[ __ ] is wasting their time doing that
right
oh yeah i mean like normal people who
are trying to get rid of those right